[Musique]
à l'heure où la lumière transperce les
arbres du musée de villèle un comité
restreint étaient invités pour
l'inauguration de la résidence
d'artistes du département patrimoine et
création
philippe gobert rend ainsi un hommage à
son regretté ami william dit williams
c'était quand même un artiste qui a
marqué l'histoire de l'art à la réunion
c'est le premier artiste avoir mis en
valeur l'image du noir à la réunion donc
tout son travail et est basée justement
sur et partez du principe qu'ils avaient
pas d'image des esclaves du noir des
marrons et donc que lui tout au long de
son activité artistique il a créé des
des symboles et des oeuvres autour
autour du noir à la rue à la réunion caf
les beaux donc c'est un artiste
important est que son oeuvre est encore
peu connu à part dans le milieu
artistique dans son entourage
et je pense que c'est une première
pierre à l'édifice une inauguration sous
la forme d'un hommage à cet artiste
plasticien autodidacte et militants à
peine entré à l'intérieur de la chapelle
pointue la voix de williams est tombée
qui pourrait montrer à l'aise
sous le regard de sa famille et amis
cette exposition multi supports a de
quoi faire réfléchir à la culture
réunionnaise visiteurs d'une part il
commence sa visite sur le parking on là
il allait présenter sur des grandes
affiches
le propos de l'exposition et les enjeux
dont le parti pris de l'artiste qui est
en résidence qui l'on doit ce travail
philippe caubère et ensuite à partir
d'un plan il s'oriente il peut se
diriger soit du côté de l'hôpital des
esclaves qui se situe à l'ouest du
domaine ou bien du côté de la chapelle
pointue qui se situe à l'ess les deux
points cardinaux
donc en fait c'est un artiste qui ne se
livrait pas facilement et je pense que
l'exposition va permettre de donner des
clés pour mieux comprendre effectivement
sa personnalité une exposition à
retrouver sans modération sur le
parcours itinérant du musée de villèle
jusqu'au 21 mars 2021
[Musique]